I have three phones one that's got all
of my contact stuff on that's got my
emails my WhatsApp my text I have
another one which is social media taking
social media off your main phone is
great don't sell the last phone it's
only worth 200 quid it doesn't matter
just keep that take social media off the
main one and then it means that you
check it when it's Wi-Fi only because
you've only got one sim card so you
can't take it out of the house with you
maybe you spend time watching YouTube or
texting or what's happening but you're
not falling down the tick tock Instagram
rabbit hole and then I have a third
phone which is the personal development
phone so that's just meditation time a
breath work like other bits and pieces
that I would use sleep with your phone
outside of your bedroom massive life
hack probably the longest lever that you
can have You're Never Gonna Roll Over in
the middle of the night and check it
you're not going to watch it before you
go to bed you're not going to use it
first thing in the morning just put it
in the kitchen jump put the charger take
the charger right now and put it in the
kitchen or somewhere else that's one
thing that I'm not doing and I need to
do and I think it's the reason why my
sleep is so much everything